last year's affiliate green appeared at
a joint hearing of the work and pension
select committee and the business select
committee to give his account of BHS is
damned fault it proved to be a pretty
memorable appearance do you remember
what you were doing on the 26th of
January 2010 11 o'clock in the morning
you must have been a migraine you in
your previous life
well you which bit of don't remember
it's difficult for you to listen today
I'm sorry are we in the same room did
you do you know I'm not looking at me
like that all the time it's really
disturbing
what blocked the deal between Sports
Direct and VHS do you know yeah one of
these the chairmen of both of those
committees Ian Wright and Frank field
are now in our Westminster studio Ian
let me start with you is this a good
outcome for BHS pensioners I think it is
welcome I think it's a milestone in this
sorry tale where many people ordinary
decent working people have been dealt a
heavy blow the principle has to be that
BHS pensioners all 20,000 of them are
not made worse off by this scheme Sir
Philip seems to have been starting to
right the wrongs that let's face facts
he himself put in place when he
extracted hundreds of millions of pounds
in the forms of dividends and the form
of other charges in BHS journeys time of
ownership but he said to you when he
appeared in front of you he said I'm
gonna sort it a lot of people was
skeptical that he would he has done he's
put his hand in his pocket he's actually
put in a lot more money than a lot of
people thought he would do is it time to
give to Philip Green a bit of credits
well let's not put the bunting out just
yet let's not crack up on the bottle of
champagne because the key point will be
the level of scrutiny and detail it
sounds a welcome step it's an important
milestone but also in terms of if you're
a very young pensioner from BHS Ian it
could be that in terms of the indexation
the way that your pension entitlement
goes up in accordance with the cost of
living that you could be quite
significantly worse off and that will
need looking at quite closely although
he has put in this inflation proofing of
1.8% Ian that looks pretty generous
compared with the current rate of
inflation but speaking to the pensions
regulator there is a chance that as I
said if you're a young
a pensioner here and that you could be
drawing down on your pension for a
considerable number of years the gap
between what you might have expected in
the present deal and the gap with what
you might have had under BHS could be
significant now I hope that's not the
case but I think it's a risk to be
identified and mitigated and certainly
Anil Frank's committee will want to look
at this - well Frank let's bring you in
at this point I mean you've said that
this isn't there are not issues which
are not sold by this which we will
obviously be looking at and the course
and everyone else will be what do you
mean by that well I mean that this is as
Ian saying a milestone an important one
but pensioners won't get the pension
increase they thought they would get but
they will all be starting at the pension
rate that they thought they and they
believed and they have actually paid in
full
that's a very I mean that's a totally
different situation to what we had when
we had to fill it before the committee
it's a success for the pension regulator
she hasn't dealt in these big figures
before and it's as a success there but
the Prime Minister before she thinks
about any knighted or anything like that
knows that there's four major reports to
come in and an Ian was touching on those
I mean that the revenue is looking into
Dominic Chapelle I think I believe
actually a writ has arrested him and
obviously released him but they're
serious charges they're looking out
there there's the Serious Fraud Office
there's the liquidator and so on and at
the end of the day we'll have a fuller
picture about what went wrong and who
dragged down BHS take what you've met
fall sorry Frank you've mentioned
Dominic chappelle's position there now
of course the the regulator has now
dropped all enforcement action against
Sir Philip
she still has enforcement action in
place against Dominic Chapelle oh and do
you think the authorities have gone far
enough yet to bring Dominic Chapelle
Tabuk no and I think by bringing him to
book whether it's through the regulator
and thereby through the courts or it's
by the revenue through the courts then
in fact we will have we might begin to
see or understand
much more of this story but the I know
Ian's committee is taking this forward
in that the the Prime Minister is really
keen on what are the lessons for
corporate government's the running of
firms the way people are treated their
pension entitlements and so on and both
Ian and I have written to the Prime
Minister to say here's a report we've
done the lessons we've drawn for private
companies the governance of large
private companies who are often we now
discover more important than many many
many public companies we're hoping that
she's going to chair a meeting at
Downing Street with the really good
examples of those who run private
companies thinking about their workers
their pensioners as well as their
shareholders and consumers and to start
to lay down rules so that other parts of
civic greens Empire like Arcadia and
other companies where there are problems
will have to be enforced to adopt good
pack the best practice okay well we'll
be discussing Arkady later in the
program but it writes we have the
pensions green paper last week it looked
like the government was backing down
from giving the Pensions Regulator real
teeth to block mergers and acquisitions
do you believe that's a mistake Frank
would know more about the pensions green
paper than I do chairing the work and
pensions committee in terms of green
papers and the Prime Minister lodged a
couple of weeks ago the corporate
governance green paper where she'd been
previously talking about workers on
boards and other things to improve the
decision-making process of companies in
our country she seems to have backed
down significantly on large parts of
that and Frank's absolutely right in
terms of many private companies that are
not listed on the stock exchange they
are massive they're massive employees
employers and have large numbers of
pensions as well and they shouldn't be
able to escape any sort of regulatory
environment that tries to protect not
just shareholders but pensioners and
employees too so you think the Prime
Minister's been nobbled by the interests
of big business then in I think you'll
have to ask the Prime Minister when you
interview her next Ian but what we want
to do on the on the base Select
Committee is look at proper governance
we're coming to the end
our inquiry now we've been looking
things like executive pay on the
responsibilities and duties of directors
because Frank's absolutely right when we
looked into BHS and the manner in which
it was sold the level of corporate
governance was absolutely appalling the
chair of the parent company wasn't even
at present at the meeting when it was
decided to sell BHS it was all a fiefdom
designed to help Sir Philip green rather
than think about the pensioners and the
employees and if we'd had proper
stringent corporate governance reporting
requirements in place perhaps this sorry
tail might not have happened does that
mean you think some of the other BHS
directors the the likes of Karren Brady
people who have places on freely green
sports they still have a have questions
to answer them there's an important part
of the Companies Act legislation it's
called section 172 and it deals with
directors duties that in terms of
directors have to think about wider
stakeholders and not just the
shareholders I think it's very difficult
to see how section 172 was adhered to
during the tail of BHS now no one's ever
been prosecuted through section 172 I
think we have to consider well why is
that the case now there there might be
reasons like judges don't want to get
into the heads of directors it could be
just bad business mistakes rather than
something perhaps more malevolent or
deliberate but certainly section 172
it's an important piece of the statute
book but has it been applied as much as
it should be one last question to you
Frank field do you think after all this
- Philip deserves to keep his knighthood
I think that's out of my hands the House
of Commons has voted unanimously that he
should lose it but a key player here
will be the prime minister who wants to
consider those four reports which is
still to come in
she's ball was careful in making these
decisions but I also know that if she
gets this one wrong people will feel
that those statements she's made up to
now that she's on their side not against
the and not on the side of the old
establishment will ring pretty hot
Hollow I'm really pleased that Sir
Philip has made this settlement today
but he's done himself untold damage in
stringing it out in this way
I've never in my whole political life
been stopped in the street and people
express such hatred for a figure as they
do for it green and it's it's appalling
he's subjected the pensioners to what
he's subjected to them the loss of jobs
which could have been unnecessary as Ian
was saying and he's lost his reputation
as well
all right elated small alright Frank
filled in lights thanks both thanks for
joining me